[Music]
there are quite a few style crimes that
grown men should avoid in professional
surroundings actually the list is
endless but I don't have long so let's
focus on one of the biggest shall we
it's this the ponytail or its hipster
equivalent the man bun here are a few
examples from my own company
DW why oh why well let me tell you why
not
what on earth are you trying to say that
you are a rebel well guess what you're
not you work for an insurance company
your house is nearly paid off and you
play a Rolling Stones records on a
record player of cost you three thousand
bucks you are not not not a rebel
you just look scruffy and a bit silly to
be honest and very dated as usual there
are exceptions if you karl lagerfeld for
example if you drive a holiday vitsin
for a living or if you're in the
business of selling narcotics to
underage customers or if indeed your
tribe or religion demands that you wear
a ponytail but if your job involves
going to a medium-sized office building
every day man get a haircut
you